on se souvient de colosse le film de
dennis hooper dans lequel des bandes
rivales s'affrontaient dans les rues de
los angeles
qui peut croire que le même phénomène
existe dans les grandes villes
françaises avec plus de 2000 jeunes âgés
de 16 à 25 ans qui se regroupent en
formant de véritables banc
nous tourner on est une bande de
chasseurs on me demande de chasseurs
contre le mouvement
un mouvement tout le monde connaît parce
qu'il ya une pub infernale autour de ce
mouvement
c'était le mouvement skinhead nous on
support papier de la xénophobie en
france ou dans le monde et on est
content le racisme en général
alors ici on est dans le métro commence
à chasser et qui ferme le rencontrer ce
crime
il ya deux ans les banques s'affronter
parce qu'il n'était pas la même banlieue
comparses n'écoutez pas la même musique
aujourd'hui ces bagarres ont changé le
sens politique distille combattre
l'extrême droite
tous
disons qu'on fait moi les skins c'est
des gens qui ont leur opinion quoi ça je
m'en fous mais chacun ses opinions pas
médisant il faut pas faux pas emmerder
le monde quoi c'est tout
on les confronte souvent avec les
skinheads ce sont les redskins
au début ce king communiste aujourd'hui
un mouvement antiraciste c'est un
mouvement qui arrive alors je m'en
prenais ce qu'il a dit mais en fin de
compte contre donc contre les sections
leaf ou parce qu'il touche au toit on
est anti raciste anti fasciste elle
arrivait largement un peu parce qu on a
commencé on a vu qu'ils ont abusé je
commence à taper les maghrébins on peut
tout ce qu'il faut savoir ce qu'il va
voir si les cils si je suis pas dans son
froc dit qui l'est ce qui n'est pas
probable fou avec ses copains et ce qui
est le mouvement le plus organisé
on les retrouve à la tête de grandes
manifestations comme celle de la cgt ou
de la cfdt
il forme aussi le véritable commando
pour attaquer pour rassemblement
d'extrême droite
hahaha
ouanna
[Musique]
le forum des halles lieu de prédilection
de tous ces marginaux de lignes de rer
est il de métro des verts chaque jour
des milliers de jeunes des banlieues au
forum on retrouve les zonards les
fugueurs les clochards aujourd'hui les
bandes il règne ici une véritable
tension une simple insulte déclenché une
véritable bataille rangée la police
minimise le phénomène de bande
pour eux à part le problème de drogue et
quelques bagarres le samedi soir
l'insécurité aux halles n'existe plus
pourtant ces banques créent leurs
propres lois
certains mêmes portent des armes
l'éduquer boys au forum depuis cinq ans
même préoccupation
chassé du skin alors tête rocky 23 ans
d'origine portugaise qui après avoir
quitté son travail devient le porte
parole de l'antiracisme messire
d'internât renvoyé de l'armée pour
indiscipline passe temps préféré la
musique et la rue le reste de la bande
est formée d'étudiants et de lycéens
leur emblème la croix celtique amputé
d'un bras
pour entrer chez les défis boys il faut
avoir plus de 18 ans et pratique est
parfaitement les arts martiaux sommes un
groupe d par le lien d'amitié
nous passons nous brisons le fascisme
sans pitié sans remords dans les loges
pendant la route bien dans les métros
aucune frontière sera biffé occupe
extreme 40 nature à l'amour pour 108 et
sans remords
on n'a pas voté je peux te dire mon gars
qui ont prétendu qu'ils veulent entendre
a parlé depuis très longtemps à new york
ou bien enfin cisco mon gars tu verras
toujours l'action du kingston et que tu
vois ici devant tes yeux ok comme tous
les samedis au marché aux puces
les ducs ibos contrôler les promeneurs
ils vérifient les assigne les badges et
même les paroles
au moindre doute sur l'opinion politique
de quelqu'un il fera ses jeunes ou un
sentiment d'exclusion et de rage il
refuse la famille pour la rue ils
refusent la société ils ont choisi la
forme la plus brutale
violente pour combattre distille
inégalités sociales
[Musique]